yeah of course
how much you seem well fit over the
shoulders to space real tight right here
and a little bit more wider right here I
knew the twelve box
robot yeah usually you don't want to
shoot like harsh sunlight like which is
what we have right now we're going to
throw a twelve by diffusion
that way we can slow down the sunlight
so basically we're going to pretend like
you know we're going to create that
diffuse look walk just what to tell you
know it's a real movie shoot when you
get rain so this way off well but slow
twelve life yeah it came looking a lot
better once he can gets in on that I
think they're here okay so some of you
may notice on Ren's Twitter there's a
glitch happening that I keep following
him back it's not a glitch I truly
enjoyed cranking rent whatever I get
because his reactions are over-the-top
just naturally if you think what he how
he says things and what he says on the
show it's fake trust me when I say no
that's him in real life and it is super
entertaining what I do is randomly on
follow up and follow them right back on
Twitter how many times of you and
falling in the fall of them and why
would that even voting so I have done
that three times a day 47 billion I
think they fell overnight
he knows me one day I was like who you
read my involvement one day is like oh I
kind of actually need to tweet rent
something but I wasn't following him
because I got mad at him so I followed
him back what I realized is when you do
things to rent in public he reacts and
it's funny the other day he almost
caught me he came up to me as I asked
what's going on I said I had no idea
it's a glitch so here we go I'm going to
unfollow her end
phone back all right there that we on
Russia
cottony co-sleeping I tried at least 20
times so are you loved Elvis he's always
taking that's like it's like good idea
now one nice thing about being on a
street that's this size is the crafts
early and then my favorite thing on set
is just going like and I'm not doing
this for demonstration I'm actually
tired
this is my fourth one that's so cool
that's pretty much one of my era movie
was quite an interesting endeavor
it essentially started out really simple
and I got fairly complicated Matt and
Trey of course did all the voices
originally they were going to pre-record
all the dialogue for the next day go
home they did that once and then after
working a 12-hour day and getting their
butts kicked
they said screw that let's just do it
live the mouse were mechanically
controlled or by an operator originally
it was meant to be this multi-million
dollar computer driven device which I
was going to feed the audio to and it
was going to drive the puppets
so that the puppets Mouse would open to
the pre-recorded dialogue which their
theory we're going to be the night
before yes there's all live tray of
joystick so they've had the perfect for
the mouth while they talk right Wow
like we're talking right now they'd be
doing it the puppets were independently
operated by hand
the mantra elements show is we're going
to do everything by hand which was
pretty interesting but very tedious yeah
but we did things like for example
instead of doing green screen there was
zero green screen in a movie which would
have been the easy way out if we had
thick dialogue in a car between two
puppets or dialogue in a jet plane they
got a hold of a bunch of cleaner devices
you know for rotating close around
cleaners putting the backgrounds and
then sewed them together so they went in
a loop oh wow if you watch closely green
stream you'll see a scene going or a
scene that makes it even that more
impressive that all that ended up
working and coming together totally how
you're supposed to laugh along this day
that we have to get rid of our camera
gear if you remember
back when first got the Canada ATB and
the 1dx that we're shooting on right
here it was all part of a marketing and
loan program through Canada
well that loan period ended before I
went to Europe and they've been hanging
us since kinda hack away what they gave
us good news is being negotiated for
some more equipment and we should be
able to keep the 1dx what we're giving
back is the EDD and a few lenses that we
never use otherwise pretty good okay so
state what about like here like not
coming out is it huh you just poked it
you asked me earlier anything
interesting in the bathroom I was like
no it's cycle cycle guy okay okay I
don't like this game of hide-and-seek
hot cold cool see 321
take 180 common so we have two cameras
and we have two monitors and wire yeah
so we can see where both cameras are
getting at the same time yeah you can
see how it looks when everything there's
no a lot of pipe
video ready and that's great guys
I love it it has a great like awkward so
this members new a higher faster version
looking at him looking at the drinks
looking at him wondering if he likes it
or doesn't like it cuz I haven't touched
it and then maybe take a sip and see if
it tastes good
yeah okay cool depen slowly try to go
roll down and action
ding-dong cut great nice okay we get one
more temperature that's it he said I was
warm I really hope this doesn't continue
happening
now we wait you're acting like this I
aren't always about how that happened I
thought I updated Twitter it's not what
you're talking about
no really yeah I keep getting
notifications that Carmichael followed
me back over and over so it's hard for
me to not believe that your message
you're not follow follow follow follow
and follow over and over again
Mulk most people if that's a weird clip
you keep telling me that it's a glitch
but with all the times you guys mess
with me it's really hard for me to
believe that so we got you care for a
little bit what have you learned from
doing lifelines so far well we're only
in the middle of the third week here out
of eight weeks so there's a whole lot of
learning left to do a lot of people
think about directing or talking to
actors there's a lot of methods people
can really approach you know the fine
performances obviously we're going with
good actors will give you good
performances because they're flexible
and they're dynamic and they can bring
depth to emotions or they can just
simply bring range to characters like
right now
the most effective thing I've found on
set and working with actors is when
wanting to get a different direction or
emotion or tone out of a scene give
people like a very clear relatable
analogy so rather than saying oh your
character's motivation is to do this or
your character's backstory or buildings
too deep into inventing information
rather than inventing it on the spot and
trying to like come up with some unique
backstory element is to give it a
foundation so that people understand so
let's say there's a scene where a person
is talking to another person through a
crack at the door you can say all right
well deliver the scene like you feel
really sorry for this
and you wish that you'd do something bad
so obviously they'll give you one
performance but then the other one is
saying I'm acting there's a monster
creeping around the house right behind
you and it's making me really really
nervous if they make sure it doesn't
find you you know a note like that
paints a very clear picture of how one
should be acting now obviously that
direction that monster now she would
work great for monster movie but when
you start combining that with a scene
that has nothing to do with monsters he
started to actually create a really
interesting in unique performance you're
taking subject matter and a context it
has nothing to do with each other and
smashing them together that's really the
biggest thing I've found so far as just
create really simple relatable
foundations moments in other movies
moments and other things people could be
familiar with stories using that
familiarity to create a performance
other than that you had a late night
I'm always it's always like 90 these
days next week's gonna be different yeah
better yeah because I'm not to be gone
set as much I'm going to go shoot with
the rock but anyways that's a whole
nother story we should begin pretty
shortly here you do think surrender
public here funny beautiful to me isn't
at all
you would use all time as a hammer
for sure Nika yeah
with every night a little bit reminds me
of my favorite thing which is we can
feel the statistics our channel with
Google Analytics and like over half of
you guys that walk Studios aren't
subscribed and really close to 700,000
subscribers if you could would consider
subscribing that make Carmichael myself
really happy also we might build across
the 1 million sooner if you guys help us
out so hey start subscribing there's a
button down below or maybe on the screen
at the end of this video